today's given by joong-gu she talked
about vector model civilizations and
after talk there is a reception so stay
in Sevilla that's great motivation I
like that okay yeah hopefully this won't
become a marathon by the end because I
know you've been been at this all day so
anyway so um yeah I'm gonna tell you
about what I will call better models and
optimization this is based on joint work
with my student halal a see who's who's
done a really wonderful job kind of
really pushing this project along so a
lot of credit should go to him but let
me jump in so uh be and I have how long
40 minutes 140 minutes okay so the
outline let me go through now I'm gonna
actually start today by talk giving a
few motivating experiments to hopefully
sort of set the stage and make you think
okay maybe this could be interesting
it's something we might want to actually
listen to after that I'm going to sort
of jump down through and talk about sort
of models in optimization what I mean by
that and then I'm going to try to make
own well sort of tangential connections
to the broader theme of this workshop
with robustness by telling you about
sort of stability and robustness in
stochastic optimization problems and
sort of add apptivity to easy problems
and that's what I mean by kind of
robustness and things like this we'll
talk about some more experimental
results and then if there's time
depending on where we are we might talk
about some extensions of this work to
relaxations of convex problems okay so
what's the so let's let's get started so
the problem in this talk for the whole
thing I'm going to be trying to minimize
a function which I will represent as
capital F this is a population objective
big f which is the expectation of a
little function f of X and s will stand
for a sample or whatever you want to
call it okay which is integral just the
expectation of your instantaneous losses
little F subject to some constraints on
our parameter vector X okay and when you
have some kind of Socastee optimization
problem like this you know you measure
your losses as an expectation under
distribution the sort of standard method
that we've all heard of is the
stochastic subgradient method right or
the stochastic gradient method which is
a simple method what we do is we take a
random sample s from our distribution
compute an element of the sub
differential of my function or its
gradient or something and then we take a
step in the negative subgradient
direction all right and many of us have
spent many years analyzing these kinds
of things so now let me ask three
questions mostly basically why do we use
this method okay I think one reason we
might use it is because it's easy to
analyze and so we like things that are
easy to analyze another reason honestly
I think is a big reason we use it is
because it's the default intenser flow
and pi torch right so you're like oh I
opened up pi torch and whoom it worked
right another reason is that it works
that was that went up for a reason you
know that's a question and it's not
clear to me that it actually does and
sometimes it does but sometimes it
doesn't so let's let's go through a
couple of plots so this is a these are
some experiments that I ran and and what
I'm plugging in these plots so we'll
spend a little bit of time on this so we
can understand it is I'm I have an
objective in this case is just the
squared error a linear regression
problem so AI transpose X minus bi
squared
averaged over some sample of size M
forgive me Peter and Peter I'm an
optimization person today so M M is the
sample size a and B or the data and X is
the optimization record I apologize this
better that's what it's gonna be for
this talk so so anyway so so this is my
objective on this axis when I'm gonna
plot on a horizontal axis I'm plotting
the initial step size I feed into my
methods okay so these are you know X
minus alpha GK so this is some initial
step size and on this axis is the number
of iterations my stochastic method takes
to solve the problem to some epsilon
accuracy what that is is not super
important so okay there are three
methods the stochastic gradient method
what I'll call the truncated methods and
we'll call the procs methods and we'll
describe what these are shortly so on
this problem whatever it happens to be
you know when the step sizes are too
small none of the methods work they
never converge when the step sizes are
right they all kind of behave
saying when a step sizes are too big the
methods don't seem to work okay seems
about right
what's that works well yeah works well
for the step size 0.1 okay just zero
yeah don't you decrease the step size
with the iterations yeah yeah we have
some kind of rate I mean this is gonna
be these kind of plots are gonna be
robust for all sorts of different rates
of decreasing the step size and things
like this so throughout we'll have a
step size which is something like Alpha
K is equal to alpha 0 K to the minus
beta where typically beta will be in
something like 1/2 to 1 and alpha 0 is
greater than 0 okay but let's see what's
that so if a supplement for 0 equals 10
hopefully it elations I mean it's an
alpha which is no no no no no sorry
sorry this is this is the number of
iterations the method runs to actually
solve the problem okay so if I'm at this
point in the plot so this might be my
initial step size was 0.2 and it took me
for 100 or so iterations to get an
epsilon accurate solution okay if I
start with a step initial step size of
10 my step size is much smaller than I
should you think so but evidently not
because because my X wins
I mean I wrote the code and it converges
and it doesn't converge right so you
might think that's true but your first
step so you went flying off to who knows
where and you know then you never got
back right I mean yeah sure if I went
for a hundred thousands I'm gonna need
this plot you know we could keep going
but I had to terminate the thing so I
could write my talk alright you know but
we could change the problem a little bit
and then not something a little bit
different happens so here's the
stochastic gradient method it still
works for you know a couple of step
sizes but then for all the ones that
doesn't work but evidently these methods
are doing better and it turns out if I
make the problem a little bit easier
than well you know these methods
whatever they are I'll tell you about
them later you know they're sort of
working four orders of magnitude more
step size that's five orders of
magnitude right there from point one up
to 10,000 yeah 10,000 okay so so I'm
gonna just start with that and say you
know maybe we shouldn't always you
stochastic gradient methods like the
other methods whatever these are seem to
work as well in some cases and in other
cases they seem to be doing better so
let me start to dig in and tell you kind
of what's going on here and explore this
a little bit okay oh there's another one
oh this is with absolute loss things get
worse okay so what do I mean by models
in optimization so we take a step back
and ask ourselves okay how do we
typically solve optimization problems
what we do is we build some good or
approximate but very simple local model
of our function f to be minimized okay
and then after we build that good but
simple local model we minimize it and
maybe we had some kind of regularization
so our steps don't go flying all over
the place okay so if if we were to do
gradient descent well what the model
that I'm going to make is a first order
model okay so I I have my point Y where
I'm trying to approximate my function
and I'm making my model around X so I'll
always use the notation F sub scripted
with X means the model is based around
the point X and what this is FX of Y is
just f of X my function plus the linear
functional which is the inner product of
the gradient with y minus X our distance
from X ok and so you can see here you
know linear function that's fairly
familiar Newton's method of course makes
a second-order model so my model around
the point X is just the two x Taylor
approximation to my function and we can
imagine you can imagine tons and tons of
other models okay but so then what we do
is sort of the generic ish strategy for
optimization is you pick some sequence
of step sizes which I'll represent by
alpha K and we iterate XK plus 1 is the
minimizer in whatever constraints it is
of F modeled around the point XK with
some regularization so we don't go
flying around all over the place okay so
that's that's what a model is in
optimization and this is kind of a
generic method and a lot of methods fall
in this framework at a classical
proximal point methods fallenness so
that's the seventies Rockafeller
gradient descent Newton's method or sort
of regularize Newton methods there's a
method that we may get to which is
called the proximal linear method which
is similar to Gauss Newton methods or xi
Burgh mark watt if you're familiar with
those there's a lot of situations where
you have things
like this right so everybody clear on
what I mean by an optimization model
proximately my function around my
current iterate minimize this
approximation all right okay so in the
stochastic case we're going to take
exactly the same approach just instead
of the true function because we can't
access that it's a high dimensional
integral or maybe we don't know the true
function because we just get samples
well what we're gonna do is draw a
sample s iid from our underlying
distribution and then we're going to
update to get our next iterate by
minimizing this model so we're gonna
minimize over our constraints and our
model is gonna be centered around the
point XK it's just now a random function
instead of the true function today we're
just gonna iterate this and of course
tons of examples fall into this the
stochastic gradient method uses linear
approximations here what are known as
stochastic proximal point methods
sometimes called implicit gradient
methods fall in this and in this case
for your sort of random realization of
your function you don't actually
approximate the instantaneous function
at all you just use f of X comma s and
then this you know probably goes back to
rockefeller in some sense but Peter
Bartlett and Brian coulis had some work
on this in 2010 oh gosh I forget kompot
SIOC is his first name and John Lankford
bertsekas - listen hey roldy a lot of
folks have done some work on these
proximal point ones there are other
these kind of stochastic Levenberg mark
watt or Gauss Newton or procs linear
methods are also some things that my
students and I worked on that fall in
this kind of framework so that's what I
mean by models so we're gonna talk today
about approximate proximal point models
where we're thinking about what this
approximation is and how it might make
us more robust or converge better or
things like this okay so we know this is
casick gradient method just makes a
linear approximation but so let me give
the three conditions and I'm gonna start
with when we do our analysis okay and
we're going to use these three
conditions throughout the talks I'm
actually going to write them on the
board
so condition one is that whatever model
I'm using is convex F X of dot comma s
okay is convex
so we're gonna leave these on the board
condition two is that the function is a
lower bound so it's a lower
approximation to my true function which
is to say that F XY s is always less
than or equal to the true value for all
Y and whatever my constraint set is and
then three I need a condition that I
have some kind of local correctness
which is to say that at the point X so
whatever my current didrik is wherever
I'm building my model my function
actually has the right value okay and my
sub differential of my model but only at
the point X whoopsie evaluated at y
equals x is contained in the true sub
differential of whatever random function
I'm getting okay so these are my three
conditions the picture is basically this
you know we have our where I have our
true function f and so the types of
models we might use are something like a
linear approximation so at x0 right this
is a linear approximation satisfies all
of these because linear functions are
convex it's correct there and it's
contained in the has the right
derivative other things we might do are
okay you know if you know your function
is non-negative you could just truncate
this approximation to 0 right
which frankly if you want to take one
home one thing home from this talk if
you are solving any machine learning
problem you have a loss function it's
non-negative you make a linear
approximation to it if your linear
function says your loss is negative it
is not a good approximation anymore
because negative numbers are not
positive right so this is the this is
I'm not kidding this is the deep insight
for this talk is that less than 0 is not
greater than or equal to 0 so you could
truncate this at 0 if you knew that you
had say a non negative loss ok
there are other things we might do how I
keep forgetting where to point this
thing some alternatives you know you can
so so we've got our subgradient
approximations we've got these kind of
truncated approximations you might say
okay maybe you can take a bundle what's
known as a bundle or a multi-line type
of approximation which would be you know
you compute sub gradients of your
function at a bunch of points and then
just take the maximum of all of these
there's all sorts of different
approximations that you might consider
using okay all right so that's what I
mean when I say a model of a function
any questions on these pictures yeah
just the not even the empirical laws
just a single observation single sample
I'm not gonna come I'm not gonna do
anything with a full sample I'm gonna do
one sample at a time everything's gonna
be fully online yeah yeah no it's
totally reasonable question and please
feel free to stop me at any point if
something is confusing yeah becomes my
expensive if your yeah so the question
is what I ever use this kind of what we
might call a bundle approximation or a
multi line approximation which is a
great question and so what we'll see in
this talk is sometimes there's kind of a
trade-off between the amount of
computation you're willing to do when
you can come when you compute an
instantaneous update and something like
the stability properties are the
long-term performance of these methods
and so this is a quite you know so
basically what you see sometimes is
there's some kind of a trade-off between
how much how careful you are willing to
be in your updates versus you know the
performance of your methods often times
frankly you don't even need to make an
approximation your function at all
because you're only computing an update
for one sample and these are very easy
functions to minimize so you may not
make any approximation to your single
you may you may make no approximation to
f of YS you might just say let's just
use that in the update because it's only
one sample it's easy all right
okay so so then you know with all of
that said all of these models are as
possibilities we're going to just
consider this family of methods that
draws a random sample and updates by
minimizing my randomly sampled function
or randomly sampled model okay okay so
let's talk about what we might call a
sort of robustness or stability type
properties for these methods you know
why why would we ever think about this
kind of generality or things like this
so
let me do let me give an example for
what we might want to think about these
things so here's a here's a linear
regression problem with no noise okay so
it's a fairly straightforward linear
regression problem I'm going to observe
literally bi equals AI transpose X star
okay and I'm gonna iterate the
stochastic gradient method on this
average quadratic loss alright so when
you actually write down these interests
you know for all iterations XK plus 1
minus X star is I that's the identity
matrix minus the outer product of your
data step size times your previous here
okay
so you're just gonna iterate this and
now if the step sizes are a little bit
too large then at least at the beginning
you can actually diverge exponentially
quickly right so you can kind of blow up
in terms of your errors right this if
the imagine the first step size times
whatever this Sigma is this covariance
here is its large then this is going to
diverge exponentially at least for the
first some number of iterations until
your step size is get nailed down a
little bit right and maybe you don't
want this kind of transient exponential
divergence that's too large you can
really get huge and numerical
instabilities for some of these problems
ok so so let's uh let's put the lid on
this and try to figure out can we avoid
this and so so here's a nice here's a
theorem that I find personally
satisfying which is the fog so if you
use this full stochastic proximal method
so remember this is I draw a random
sample and I just minimize the single
observation function plus a quadratic so
often this is a simple one dimensional
type optimization problem they're not
super hard to solve then as long as the
minimizer's of your population exists
so it's non-empty and you have a finite
variance of your gradients at the
optimum not everywhere just at the
optimum that's all I care about
then my expected distance of my interet
to the optimum it's bounded by my
initial distance plus a sum of squared
step sizes okay you think well that
doesn't tell me much but it does tell
you something it tells you you'll never
diverge exponentially and as long as
your step sizes are square summable
which is a typical condition for example
if your step size is satisfied beta
between 1/2 and one then this says you
will never diverge
well you just won't diverge so these
methods cannot diverge ever no matter
what your problem is as long as at the
optimum when you have
my variance right and then it turns out
actually under the same assumptions
you're actually guaranteed convergence
these can I mean I'm not gonna give you
a rate in this sort of absurd generality
but you will converge the distance to
the optimal set remains bounded and this
distance will converge to zero as your
iterates go to infinity all right just
to give you kind of a an example where
this wouldn't happen so think about your
function suppose you have the function f
of X equals e to the X plus e to the
minus X ok
you aren't gradient descent on this if
you start away from zero and use
essentially any step size you're going
to find yourself start oscillating very
quickly and you will actually diverge
whereas this of course you know at x
equals zero the derivative is 2 no zero
sorry
average whatever the derivative is a
constant or less and so it won't diverge
when you run these methods okay so
already we're seeing a little bit of
benefit all right so you get this kind
of robustness for free now you might ask
okay well this for stochastic proximal
method that might be kind of expensive
there are weakening zuv this where you
only have to solve this two reasonable
accuracies and then everything still
goes through exactly the same way not
going to spend too much time on them
though but this does show you that you
know if you can spend a little bit of
more computation to actually solve this
update then you can get a lot of
benefits at least in theory okay here's
another theorem which basically just
says if you actually have some kind of
strong convexity or expected strong
convexity of your objectives meaning
that your random functions are lower
bounded by a quadratic this may be low
rank but some kind of quadratic then
these things actually converge so you
will converge an expectation and the
rate at which you will converge is
basically K that's your iterates times
your step size squared so you will
actually converge no matter what and we
can give an explicit rate for this
yeah so what you see I mean this this
alpha K is what's determining this oh
you want to do something like newer
descent or something like that yeah I
haven't done the analysis but let me the
the steps that we go through are exactly
the steps you go through to prove
convergence of mirror descent and things
like this so so I can I mean I can work
through the proof that nothing will
change if we were to do that I mean it
would some things about how you measure
distances and stuff would change but at
least at this asymptotic level nothing
would nothing would be different I don't
know I mean this there's no rate right
it's just that it goes to zero and so
there's no rates or anything like that
here you might be able to see some
differences because you'd be measuring
the variances in a different way and so
that that's certainly plausible but and
and what that is what would happen but
we didn't we didn't go through that but
yeah you could push through this through
and kind of mirror to some settings yeah
so suppose that equals what happens I
don't I don't I don't know what happens
outside of my beta equals one half to
one I mean when beta is bigger than one
it definitely won't converge cuz it just
doesn't make enough progress
it just terminates early when beta is
less than 1/2 I'm less clear I don't
know exactly what would happen I mean
the average dinner it's would have some
kind of convergence but whether the
actual iterate itself would converge I'm
not sure I don't know
the various water uh yeah so the
question is my advocate is one possible
conclusion of this bigger batches would
be better because variance would be
smaller my R is the results in this
paper don't really speak to that and
actually a big open question here is
like how you would treat bigger batches
in this kind of iteration because it
would get more computationally expensive
to perform the updates yeah no no no
that's that's totally it's a great
question and I honestly don't know the
answer I mean that's that to me that's
an open question like if I have parallel
computation or things like this where I
can do big batches can I extend some of
these results in these ideas and I don't
know it's that I'm not sure yet so so
maybe but yeah we haven't we haven't
nailed it down enough to be able to
answer that convincingly I do list it as
an open question at the end though okay
all right so um so that's that so just
just kind of a fun example so this is
what happens on this least-squares
objective where you run stochastic
gradient method this is five different
runs and you can see that over the first
hundred or so steps stochastic weighting
method does diverge exponentially in
terms of its loss and then it kind of
gets it nailed back down eventually
right and then the proximal point and
these related methods yeah they just
kind of get down to the optimum
reasonably quickly I mean I both getting
there eventually it's just one of them
gets there a lot more quickly than the
others okay yeah so we can as I said we
don't really need this full proximal
point method you can do accurate enough
approximations things are going to be
okay
and I'm happy to tell you what those are
offline there we don't really need
convexity for some of these results and
we may talk about those as well there
are some kind of weaker notions of well
what's called weak convexity or semi
convexity there are fifteen names for
this it's Jason here no you know some
other ones but I don't remember them all
anyway
so so there we can we can kind of go
beyond what I've said before okay so let
me let me now give a give some rate that
some results that actually have rates of
convergence
fated to them okay so let's start with
this classic theorem on averaging in
stochastic gradient methods by Polya
candidates key so the theorem is if F
our population is convex and it's
strongly convex in your X star the
optimum point and our functions are
smooth our random functions are smooth
meaning their derivatives are Lipschitz
then if we run the stochastic gradient
method asymptotically the average of the
iterates or the average distance sort of
normalized by root K converges in
distribution to a normal with a mean 0
and inverse Hessian inverse Hessian and
covariance this is kind of intuitive the
more curvature you have the easier the
problem should be the more variance
there is at optimum the harder the
problem should be okay this assumes some
kind of global smoothness and things
like this so it turns out if you run any
of our approximate methods as long as
you can guarantee that the iterates
remain bounded period if they remain
bounded so they don't diverge to
infinity then you're going to get this
asymptotic normality so you know you
don't require that the F X's are smooth
globally you only require that in some
neighborhood of x star the true optimum
they are smooth so for example this
result does not apply to the function e
to the X or if you're a statistician it
doesn't apply in Poisson regression or
most G LMS whereas here if you have a
nice enough approximation that you
remain bounded where the heck are if you
remain bounded then as soon as you have
satisfied these three conditions convex
model it's a lower bound and it's
locally correct it doesn't even matter
if your models are differentiable I
don't actually care about that then you
will get this optimal asymptotic
normality okay and that is the optimal
asymptotic covariance so that's the
local asymptotic minimax theorem says
that this is optimal and and basically
the key insight here is that because we
know when we use these models that we
will converge with probability one
eventually even if our approximations
are say this truncated thing and are not
differentiable there are some kind of
variational principles that say
eventually we're almost doing a
stochastic gradient procedure really
close to the optimum even if we're not
quite doing it there's some there's some
nice analytic tools you can do to get
this
so you get this kind of nice asymptotic
normality result no matter what your
objectives are as long as you have
smoothness in your X star you can blow
up exponentially super exponentially
outside of things it doesn't matter okay
all right so now what I think yeah oh
sorry Leon I didn't see you're behind a
pillar why can I assume that that's a
good question yeah so why I can assume
that is because I have this theorem
which is that if I use the stochastic
proximal point method or a good enough
approximation to it and I can quantify
what that means very precisely if you
want me to but I'll do it offline maybe
then with probability one the supreme
uhm of the distance between XK and the
optimal set is bounded I don't care what
the bound is just that it remains it
never diverges so with probably all I
care that it's less than infinity and
then at least in some asymptotic sense I
will get this rate of convergence which
is 100 K with the optimal covariance
structure at the end of the day okay
yeah so that's why I can assume the
interest remain bounded oh you know
there's some lower order terms that's
why I'm doing asymptotics I don't know I
honestly have no idea but that's uh but
yeah so that's a good question that in
like the standard cases have Lipschitz
functions and things like this we can
recover all of the standard results but
here I'm not totally sure what the
higher-order terms would be okay so so
let me now talk about what I think are
kind of a fun set of problems that have
recently started cropping up which are
what I'll call easy problems okay
and by easy problem I mean something
that has a sort of consistent solution
for all of our samples so so what does
an easy problem an easy problem is
something like an interpolation problem
so this if you if you've been following
me Chapelle can Sasha Rockland Sasha see
Birkhoff Daniel - I forget meet rus' my
first name and others you know they've
talked about stochastic optimization
problems or statistical learning
problems where the solution a good
solution literally interpolates the data
perfectly has zero loss as zero training
error okay and still has good
statistical performance another kind of
easy problem meaning you have a perfect
solution for all your samples when your
systems that are over parametrized or if
you want to find a point that's in a
intersection of convex sets so let's
talk about easy problems so an easy
problem when I say easy problem I mean I
want to minimize a function f of X but
the problem is easy if there's an X star
such that for all of your samples s F
that X star is actually equal to the
infimum value of f of X okay so like you
actually perfectly fit all of your
samples you're like you know if you're a
statistician you know if you're one of
my students at Stanford your front
steven is frowning a lot he's unhappy
with this but there are reasons to think
that this might actually happen there's
a lot of problems say like deep learning
where you perfectly interpolate the
training data and it seems to do okay
right and there are there are a number
of others but we're gonna impose one
additional condition here okay so in
addition to my addition it's one through
three or one two three I'm gonna have
condition for which is that my model is
always above the minimal value of the
instantaneous loss F X Y s is always
greater than or equal to infimum over
all oh let's write Z Z F of Z yes okay
so this would be you know if you have a
squared error say you know linear
regression then zero is this value for
most machine learning problems zero is
this value okay you just know your loss
is minimized when it takes the value 0
okay and so I'm just gonna truncate all
my models at this minimal value so in
addition to one through three I'm gonna
have this fourth condition that you have
the lower bound and that's it and then
once you've got this
you can prove a number of interesting
things so let's suppose that F satisfies
this growth condition which is basically
strong convexity okay or a slightly
weaker version which is that f of X goes
at least quadratically away from the
optimal set then you can prove that in
expectation the distance of your inner
it from the optimal set squared is less
than the maximum of e to the minus some
of your step sizes and e to the minus K
times the initial distance okay and C is
a constant that depends on lambda in a
slightly weird way so I don't want to
get into it okay so no matter what your
step size sequence is as soon as you
have this lower bound condition that's
four you're basically adapting and
getting this exponential or linear
convergence right and it happens no
matter the step sizes and there have
been results like this in these kind of
interpolation type problems but
typically they require sort of very
precise exact step size choices that
reflect knowledge of the problem that
you typically wouldn't have you know and
also the step size choices won't work in
other problems say like where you aren't
perfectly separable data okay so another
another class of problems where we
actually have some you can show fast
convergence of these methods as soon as
you have one two three and four as your
conditions is what are known as problems
with sharp growth so this is to say f of
X grows at least linearly away from X
star okay so where might you have
something like this this would be say if
you have a piecewise linear objective or
maybe you have some kind of hinge loss
or you have a classification problem say
where your data is perfectly separable
okay so then you if you actually look at
these problems and write down how they
grow away from the optimum you'll see
that they actually have kind of level
curves which are basically growing
linearly away from the optimal set right
another example would be say you want to
find a prop a point in the intersection
say of three convex sets C 1 C 2 and C 3
okay so here's our intersection of these
sets well then a nice objective that's
going to be minimized only on that
intersection is the sum of your distance
to each of these sets okay
and that also you can prove is going to
satisfy this kind of sharp growth
condition all right so as soon as you
have a problem like this say finding a
point on the intersection of convex sets
or a separable classification problem
then when you iterate these methods as
long as you satisfy one through four you
will get again fast linear convergence
right so this is not you know one on
square root K or one on K this is
exponentially fast e to the minus K or e
to the minus some of your step sizes all
right yeah
nothing
yep yes you can take off it to be
literally infinity but these problems
are very special right they say that
there is a consistent solution that
works for all of your data right but the
key is that you have this condition that
says your model is always an upper bound
on the informal value that your function
takes so you actually stop your models
you truncate them and say zero just
Thresh a little bit amount yeah it's
it's linear but there's some kind of
dependence on the variability in your
sampling which I am sweeping completely
under the rug it's in the paper which
you can certainly look at basically for
well-conditioned problems C looks nice
for poorly conditioned problems C looks
less nice there's some kind there's some
kind of conditioning going on in there
that I didn't really want to get into
but yeah it's it's important to actually
nail down what that is and we do it in
examples in the paper money into gold
so like overestimating if you
overestimate it yeah well if you
overestimate the infimum then you're no
longer going to have this lower bound
condition which is that your model is
always also lower than your function
right so you can't satisfy this while
being too large on your guess of this
guy you just can't and so I don't
actually know what happened but luckily
for most problems you're doing like the
squared error exponential loss logistic
loss hinge loss your infimum is always
zero you're just like it's a loss it's
lower bounded by zero let's call it a
day yeah you know we can talk about that
later I mean there are other cases where
you can compute saturations actually
exactly I mean and I should just say
like you know even if your problem is
not in this sort of ridiculous easy
setting where everything has the same
solution you know you can still write
down these four things and you will
still get convergence in all of the
standard cases you know you will be
adaptive if you don't happen to get an
easy problem it'll still work it's just
it will work a lot better if you get an
easy problem in a nice way so
you salt them and then you keep going
because he wanted you're not actually
optimizing you know you're optimizing
something as a proxy for your test error
right in the in the sense that these
methods will give you the same solution
that if you ran the stochastic gradient
method to infinity they if that works
then these will work you know they'll
just get there a lot faster
among the optimal solutions among the
optimal solution basically you would get
the solution that's in the span of your
data which is the minimum norm solution
or the minimum of norm interpolant so
that's the one you'll get which not
always clear if that's exactly the one
you want but that's the one we've well
not we like Belkin MA Vassili and all of
those collaborators have been analyzing
is these sort of minimum norm and
turbulence and that's what we will get
to yes okay
this would get you to the maximum
marginal solution yes yeah if you were
doing like the hinge loss for a
classification problem would be max
margin yeah all right so let's let's
revisit some of these experimental
results just so we can kind of
understand them more in the context of
the results I've been talking about so
remember we're iterating minimize our
random model and we're gonna compare
three methods one is to cast a gradient
one is this truncated method where
literally I'm like okay my function is
non-negative so I'm just gonna take the
positive part of my linear approximation
and the last one is I'm actually gonna
run the full stochastic proximal point
method so I'm actually gonna just solve
the full update exactly all right so
we're gonna compare these three so
here's a here's a here's a first
experiment so this is linear regression
problem where the noise in our
observations for bi is fairly small okay
I'm sorry I should know what it is but I
don't remember and what you see is that
you know there's some regime where the
stochastic gradient method is convergent
say between step size is 0.1 and 1 the
full proximal method is convergent for a
wider range of step sizes and it turns
out in this experiment actually these
truncated methods where you just say
stop going once you hit zero have great
convergence for this five orders of
magnitude worth of step sizes hey then
if you have no noise these things all
well the truncated and proximal methods
work superbly they very quickly find the
solution again it's the cascading method
even though this problem is trivial
there is no noise this cascading method
worked for the step size of 1/2 and like
0.5 and very quickly does not function
as well here's a mini regression problem
with what I'll call poor conditioning
okay this actually this one I did
include this bundle method where we did
two linear approximations to our
function so this is linear regression
with poor conditioning on our data
matrix okay so you can see I change the
colors I apologize the Casa gradient
method in red never gets to accuracy
better than 0.05 all right so who has an
idea of what the poor conditioning means
in this problem
yeah what's a bad condition number on
the data matrix okay it's very close
this is condition number 15 right so so
I mean I ran this experiment I was like
this can't be right
like a condition number 15 is not poorly
condition but it turns out it's right
you know I mean if you ran long enough
eventually this will converge but it's
just not converging as soon as the data
is a little bit off of isotropic
Gaussian random vectors right which you
should yeah I don't know to me this
gives me pause about relying on
stochastic gradient methods okay
absolutely regression loss is no noise
you know similar story narrow range of
step sizes where the stochastic gradient
method works others work for
substantially more you just get a little
bit better approximation multi-class
hinge loss okay
sorry experimentally if there is a lot
of noise if there is a lot of noise so
this is what's happening here's uh okay
so here's what's happening I put in a
bunch of noise in this absolute
regression experiment okay and this
massive shaded area is actually a 95
percent confidence interval on what's
happening and the truncated method and
the proximal point method are actually
right on top of each other so that they
have exactly the same behavior and this
pretty good problem so what you see is
with this Matt a lot of noise case this
gas agreement that has a narrow window
where it converges these proximal and
truncated methods have a broader range
of convergence it's not you know this
full massive thing that you saw before
but it is a little bit more robust to
your step size choice say you know
instead of just 0.1 you're getting maybe
one additional order of magnitude here
and then sometimes it still works out
here so it's not it's not like a panacea
but it's when it's easy it nails it and
when it's not easy it's at least a
little better and sometimes more and
it's basically free to inframan
implement this method at least okay
multi-class change losses no noise
here's multi-class change loss with a
little bit of label flipping say like
what was this 1% flipping of labels and
here you can again still see that these
truncated and proximal plain methods are
getting much better behavior terms of
conversion
and then more annoys again you see that
the behaviors start to get closer
together but there's still a gap here's
some non convex problems so this is
minimizing absolute value of x squared
minus B because we can and again you see
something actually fairly similar
basically you can you run an analogue of
what I'll call these the truncated
methods let's recall it procs Wiener
method stochastic reading or full
proximal methods and again stochastic
gradient method narrow window of step
sizes where it's functional everything
else much broader you guys are probably
getting bored with these matrix
completions same thing happens I did an
experiment with C far because neural
networks are a again you know the
stochastic gradient method and
stochastic greeni methods its momentum
have sort of a narrow regime of steps
this is where they work when you
truncate the loss at zero there's a
broader range of step sizes where things
still converge I should say this with
full caveats we need to do a lot more
experiments with neural nets but they
just take a while and we haven't
finished them all so I'm sorry that's it
okay so then I was gonna talk about this
if time but I think I will skip all of
this doo-doo-doo-doo doo-doo-doo-doo and
okay conclusions so you know I think the
first conclusion is that you know maybe
pert and I know you guys believe this
but it's not clear to me that we always
sort of live by this but like blind
application of stochastic gradient
methods is not always the right answer
and if you're a little bit careful and
just do a little better modeling of the
problem you have at hand you can get a
lot better performance you know and
sometimes strikingly better performance
you can adapt to a problem difficulty
you can be more robust to large
variances and your functions all sorts
of things you know there's often
considerations of computational
efficiency when you choose the models
that you want to minimize and so there
might be some trade-offs between
computation versus convergence we
haven't totally nailed those down but
it's clear if you're willing to pay a
little bit more for computation you can
do better there's a bunch of open
questions left here you know it's I
think it's a lot of fun to work on these
you know there are questions of sort of
how do we actually adapt to functions
you know what about the second-order
terms and a lot of our bounds because
certainly some of mine were asymptotic
how do you deal with parallelism so all
of this was kind of single observation
at a time you know fully
Winchell methods I didn't talk about
parallelism or mini-batches or any of
that at all I don't know how to do it
and I think it's a I'd love to
understand better how you can actually
solve those types of problems so thanks
a lot for your attention and I'm happy
to take more questions
more questions
what's what's the worst ratio you come
across how much it cost to minimize the
yeah I mean I've come I mean of course
we could make them really bad right but
yeah so I think you know I think that
there's a set of experiments that I
haven't done all right sorry I didn't
include we've done them which is known
as say like post song regression so in
Poisson regression your objective is
something like f of X a B is equal to X
of a X basically - be a X okay so you
want to minimize this plus a quadratic
function of X all right and that's
actually not that hard it's a
one-dimensional problem but there's no
closed-form or anything you have to
develop some kind of iterative methods
for it and the question of whether this
you know so you want to minimize this
well sorry this plus you know 1/2 X - x
squared this isn't hard particularly but
it does take you know whatever you want
to solve it to epsilon accuracy is gonna
take log one on Epsilon sort of steps at
every iteration instead of just one step
and so you know there's gonna be some
trade-off in terms of stability and
convergence and I wish I had the plots I
didn't do any real serious timing
comparisons we were just looking at
iteration complexities you know that
there are certainly going to be worse
examples
I think experimenting CIPA looks pretty
aggressive I'm just wondering like when
you change your model to like was
truncated like below and I was only we
applied that to none how exciting to see
something about fun in stationary point
or yeah you can so that's an interesting
question here's a type of result I can
show okay
so let's suppose you have a weakly
convex objective which means that if you
add a big enough quadratic becomes
convex if this thing has sharp growth
and this is a weird conditional result
and for some reason you converge to a
global optimum which often you do then
that convergence is going to be really
fast it's going to be asymptotically
linear or exponential depending on how
you think about these things okay so we
have results like that which are not
100% satisfying but we can prove that
you converge the stationary points we
can prove that if you converge the right
one it'll happen super fast but those I
think are about as much as you could
possibly hope for doing some kind of
compact yeah we need some kind of weak
convexity or something like this but
there are still reasons to do better
approximations we can prove convergence
in more general scenarios with better
approximations completely you know sort
of a parallel story for the weakly
convex cases for the convex case but the
convex case everything is kind of it's
clear what's happening more so than in
this weird like if you converge then you
do it fast kind of thing okay should we
do let's do one more and then we'll
that's a great question I think it's
trained accuracy no no no sorry it was
86% it was test accuracy it was a it was
test accuracy yeah but but again you
know this we don't have confidence
intervals for that experiment it was
like we did two and they both looked
good and then I put it in the slides and
I was like we better run some more and
then he'll all was like yeah the more
senior students keep using all the
computers and they won't let me get any
computer time and then I'm here this is
it's like having children you know like
my one-year-old punches my three year
old my senior students take all the
computers right you know these guys are
all innocent they're none of my students
so these Stanford students are good ones
[Applause]